a mother and her teenage son are at odds
over the safety of childhood vaccines
high school senior Ethan Linden Berger
says his parents misguided beliefs about
his health and the health of his younger
siblings put them at risk
he recently defied his mother and got
vaccinated dr. taryn a ruler shows us
what can happen when children raised in
anti vaccine households start to get
their own information Terre good morning
good morning John
Ethan Linden Berger says he turned to
Reddit an online message board to help
him find the truth about vaccines
after reading scientific papers and
journals he came to the conclusion he
had to disobey his mother and get
immunized I questioned her judgment but
not her care for most of his life Ethan
Linden Berger thought it was normal for
most kids not to get immunized but about
two years ago he began to see how the
posts about vaccines his own mother was
sharing on social media were dangerous
you have someone like measles which is a
preventable disease that we can
vaccinate against that I and many people
believe is coming back because of
opinions like the ones that have
influenced my mom in November linden
Berger asked strangers on reddit where
he could go to get up-to-date with his
shots
my parents are kind of stupid he wrote
god knows how I'm still alive I was like
what I was just blown away
Jill wheeler is his mother there's a
degree of feeling like you know he
doesn't trust what I say as a parent the
intention of that wasn't to blame my
parents for anything or make them look
dumb you know that again I came from a
place of frustration and trying to deal
with this issue and find common ground
Linden burgers showed his parents
scientific studies that showed vaccines
were safe and effective but his mother
remained unconvinced I think it was just
straight-up fear of him getting these
immunizations and having a bad reaction
I think a lot of people look at this as
a straight black and white answer and I
don't feel like it is Linden Berger is
18 and in Ohio he's old enough to get
shots without his parent's permission in
December he got vaccinated for influenza
hepatitis tetanus and HPV
his 16 year old brother who's now
considering also getting his shots will
have to wait there is no federal law
mandating children be immunized only
seven states and Washington DC allow
minors to get vaccinations without
parental consent I'm very proud of him
for standing for what he believes in
even if it is against what I believe
it's um he's a good boy it's a good kid
Ethan is getting his next round of
vaccinations later this month
anti vaccine conspiracy theories often
use pseudo scientific language which
makes them both potent and enduring as
we've seen with the measles outbreak in
Washington and Oregon there is a very
real risk when parents buy into those
half-truths what the mom yeah yeah that
they can talk together on so Terra where
if you're out there looking would you go
other than Reddit where where should a
parent get accurate information so the
American Academy of Pediatrics the CDC
there are many other web sites where
parents can get a lot of information
that have studies actually debunking
some of the common myths but I think one
of the big biggest and best places is to
just sit with your health care provider
the pediatrician and have an open frank
and non-judgmental discussion you know
it's been shown in surveys that
pediatricians can really do a lot
because a lot of these parents you know
with just the right information they can
make choices that may be better ones for
their family and the motive is not
judgmental dentures on there are not too
many parents that could say on national
TV
expecially when he has slammed her that
way even he's a good kid and I
appreciate him speaking up I know I'm
right mom we talked about the dangers of
the internet now the power of it too
with Ethan being able to do this
research on its own exactly exactly
thank you